[Music]
guys with 74 playable fighters and 103
stages at launch smash bros ultimate has
more content than any smash game that
came before it and while we love all the
characters in this iconic Nintendo
franchise some of them frankly just get
under our skin so sit back and try not
to get too tilted as we rank the top 10
most annoying smash bros ultimate
characters to play against kicking off
our list is the world's ultimate nano
machine powered mercenary Solid Snake I
mean Solid Snake it's like one of my
Japanese enemies in the Metal Gear
series snake is a man who will do
whatever it takes to complete his
mission and his Smash Bros iteration is
no different
I'm just gonna really comfortably go
higher drop down with the grenades oh my
lord
salem with the conversions once you get
past his arsenal of grenades mortars c4s
and rockets you still have to deal with
the fact that snake players are always
willing to throw you both into the
explosion then I can't see it right now
but somewhere I'm smiling
and so if MPD what a trade snake mates
why do they do it you enjoy all the
killing that's why the ninth place on
our list goes to the V fighters ah yes
me fighters allowing you to play as a
joke of a character since 2014 the
reason the characters are so annoying is
that no one knows how to play against
them including you yeah oh my god he
might go ready for that win are you
kidding me now if you do find yourself
up against Amy Maine
chances are you're playing against some
sick masochist who's dedicated their
entire life to confusing and infuriating
their opponents with a Zed to your
character oh my gosh what I haven't seen
half his moveset he held back half his
power our number eight spot goes to the
leader of the DK crew Donkey Kong this
lovable eight might be a fan favorite
but he's still annoying as hell to play
against and this Kong is one heavy guy
which means he lives a lot longer than
you'd expect for just how fast he is his
side B attack his armored and buries
making it way better for getting back on
stage than it has any right to be and
his signature giant punch comes with
armor to right now it really looks
pretty darn good putting with this
advantage disma meant to squeeze don't
get some off stage George another part
I've been that kill was it wasn't the
full punch I think if it was top it all
off with the best taunt in the game and
you've got a character that's liable to
make you go apeshit
what what did i do one of the games
early frontrunners for top tier Falls at
the number 7 spot on our list pal ooh
Tina is fast zones you up forever and
has great kill power but nothing about
her is more annoying than the 8000 times
a match you're going to hear this that's
right
Paulo Tina's Nair is the most annoying
thing about her it's got a huge hitbox
tons of damage and great combo potential
already at 91 if bad things is just a
little bit all right no more as we have
another stock round claim air Dodgers
throat back throat knock in a ko this
time that drop down yup from the near
selling show off the glass tone taking
his first stop hovering it perfectly
whip that Nair
you hate seeing it but most importantly
you hate hearing it too taking the
number 6 spot on our list is Ganondorf
now look smash is a fun game but when
you're up against a Ganondorf player
they'll always find a way to make you
feel bad just for playing the character
is far from top-tier he's incredibly
slow and his recovery is laughable but
if you slip up for even a second you'll
get caught out by one of his slow but
devastating moves once you get hit by
his F smash up tilt warlock punch or
wizards foot you'll regret even picking
up the game in the first place yo good
night good night good night see you
later I get coming in at the number 5
spot is the wrestling Pokemon in cinah
roar
[Music]
in center or really brings the hype at
least if you asked wrestling fans
[Applause]
everyone else on the other hand is just
too pissed off because they died at 50%
uh-huh
okay die in sin Aurora hits like a truck
and you're probably gonna get killed by
a random side become and grab because
you decided to hold down shield like a
reasonable person when I play against in
sinner or online I imagine my opponent
looks a little something like this
couple that with his revenge counter and
you've got one of the most annoying
characters in the game a comeback King
don't go so guys there are a lot of
sword fighters in smash ultimate but
none are more annoying than kromm which
is why he takes the number 4 spot on our
list this Fire Emblem character has an
incredibly powerful move set combining
both explosive power and incredible
speed if there's the attack sweet with
the answer ok and if you don't know what
you're doing you'll find yourself dead
to a lightning fast F Smash sure his
recovery is pretty much non-existent but
you don't need to recover if you never
lose the neutral good patience and if by
some chance you do get him offstage
kromm is going to take you down with him
[Music]
at the number 3 spot we have the vampire
fighting duo Simon and Richter Belmont
but more specifically this spot goes to
their arsenal of whips bows crosses holy
water and axes that up tilt was smart
but he wasn't able to actually catch up
with the close oh he actually wanted a
harder punish I see
playing against the Belmonts turn smash
from a platformer fighter into a bullet
hell shooter where you're dodging
projectiles for minutes at a time before
you even get a chance to press one of
your own buttons
I'd hate I think he was just calculated
about that I trust him to be that smart
the way the way he's been playing I
trust him to be that smart no he's just
f children and it's good he's in the
perfect spot it can take an eternity to
get through their onslaught of
projectiles and by the time you do they
can just escape with their down tilt and
start the fun all over again okay never
mind
no holed up playing against the Belmonts
really makes you wish Dracula won well
if you thought the Belmonts were
annoying just wait till you see our
runner-up entry that's right it's none
other than the kremlin king himself k
rool this crocodile is one thick boy so
even if you manage to get around his
crown and blunderbuss you still have to
deal with his nearly endless super armor
[Music]
you're alive you can hit K rool all you
want but he'll power through it and
snack you clean in the face but now
let's be clear here K rool isn't good
he's huge he's combo food he doesn't
actually do anything but if you let your
guard down for even a second he'll bury
you with his down throw take your stock
and send you into an instant tilt spiral
I couldn't have said it better myself
taking the number one spot on our list
is one of the best characters in the
game Oh Lamar he and his Pikmin may be
small in stature but that won't stop
them from three stalking grass it really
seems to me that all of our becomes one
of the very best characters in the game
when he has multiple partners Oh Lamar
controls the game at every second he's
got the disjointed hitboxes of a sword
character the amazing projectiles of his
owner an incredible recovery the range
and kill power of a character four times
his size and one of the smallest hurt
boxes in the game oh and there we go
your your champion right now and to make
it all worse his Pikmin are so small you
won't even know you got hit with one
until it's too late you're all I'm gonna
say is that this matchup the glucose
fever that bus got purples and now it's
over now it's another double purple we
have again 300 came back to stage Alomar
is the most annoying character to play
against in ultimate he literally does it
all oh my god I never get that percent
you can the game is starting to escape
from right now 75% we got a great
pigment line up here for shootout as
well how appropriate we got a angel a
goddess on stage because it's gonna take
a miracle for now with a bring this one
back and
we'll beat the mad chute on the three oh
come back
well guys that is our list now look if
there is a smash bros ultimate character
you find annoying as hell and they
didn't make it on or you want to see
your favorite game get the same
treatment let us know in the comments
below and that's the bottom line
because Colin said so thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button